I think you're going to like the CNN had
a segment on Thursday where they put
Trump supporters in a room to talk about
how well they think Trump has done as
president and it went exactly the way
you would imagine it would go trumps
approval rating is in the trash lowest
of any president at this point in their
presidency out of the six Trump
supporters in the room five gave Trump's
performance so far and a rating and one
guy gave him a B because he said he
doesn't give any president in a meaning
B is basically the highest rating that
this guy would give to a president these
are not cherry picked clips that I'm
going to play for you okay this was a
pretty short segment we're including a
lot of what was said by these Trump
supporters also the first woman we're
going to hear from if you're watching
check out the size of the cross on this
woman's necklace on the right the size
of a flag pin or cross determines you
know how good of a right-winger you are
I guess take a listen to this I feel
that he is trying to like loosen up the
restraints on business and I know he's
trying with the health care but he I
know that didn't work out as well as we
had hope it didn't work out at all yeah
well it's true again and they you have
to adjust it a little bit yeah Trump
said he would start making moves on
Obamacare to repeal it on day one didn't
happen Trump in the White House rallied
around a disastrous health care bill
then Trump realized it wasn't going to
go his way so it ultimately got pulled
by Republicans it's been a complete and
utter failure and this is why the woman
is gave a giving Trump and a let's
continue I give them an A based on what
the TPP nutsy stone pipeline the Dakota
access pipeline the the travel
restriction fantastic
and I know it's wait wait wait Polanco
travel ban hasn't gone into effect the
travel benefits are down by two courts
it's not in this this guy is giving
Trump a positive rating because of both
two travel bans have been destroyed by
our judicial system and they're giving
Donald Trump an A for effort even though
he has both houses of Congress on his
side and he's been playing golf so much
more
yeah and he's been playing golf Trump
didn't have anything to do with pulling
out a TPP TPP was dead months ago the
pipelines are a joke oil sands are
outdated dirty form of energy with low
demand it would create a few dozen jobs
and and the
as travel bans that this guy loves were
declared uh we're blocked because of
they were determined to be illegal okay
let's continue to the next a genius we
see that he's working with Ford Motor
Company to build three plants in the
United States and and a major-league
investment in the United States as
opposed to moving those jobs or keeping
those jobs in Mexico
alright that's huge that's been debunked
Trump bragged about keeping jobs at Ford
but Ford said Trump had nothing to do
with it and they made these plans a long
time ago so does anyone in the room
support Trump for a real reason let's go
to our next contestant I think the last
what seventy days whatever it's been now
have been positive because we've started
to learn a lot more things we've started
to see such as just how how the process
works in Washington the fact that health
care failed I think shows business and
politics are not only the same thing
because if they were I think that deal
would have gotten done and would have
gotten done a lot more quickly
so maybe what that tells us is politics
needs to change completely
unintelligible I can't even comment on
that one because this woman has no idea
what she's talking about I mean she this
is someone who votes she has no clue
what's going on around her
I thought Trump as a businessman would
be able to get things done because he's
used to making deals like this yeah but
apparently not let's continue on to our
next our next guests businesspeople are
earned a good negotiators are by nature
people that bring opposing parties and
different people who are in factions
together and that's what he's attempted
to do why wasn't he able to close the
deal can all politicians or dividers
yeah Trump brings people together who is
Trump brought together this is called
confirmation bias where you assume the
conclusion and then find a way to make
it fit by rationalizing and another term
for what these people are experiencing
is Doc's astok closure a closed loop of
reasoning and I think it applies to this
clip as well it's this very intangible
kind of sense of you know forget about
all the noise forget about the Russia
forget about you know all you know
Maxine Waters and Nancy Pelosi and Chuck
Schumer all the noise that they're
making if you kind of tune all that out
there is just this this very quiet
restoration
of of law and order and yeah if you
forget about the daily scandals and lack
of accomplishing every anything at all
things are going really really great and
you're led less left with something
intangible there
I like that if you ignore everything bad
Trump's doing fantastic path
oh yeah it's like Nixon was a fantastic
president if not for that Watergate I
never right okay and we've got a couple
more Clips here take a look specifically
tangibly what has he done in the past 60
plus days to fight Isis well I mean we
had that you know there was a there was
a tak that was done in Basel it went
terribly awry that one was considered
bad but I know that we have somebody who
is going to be very aggressive
aggressive yeah all of the actual things
Trump has done to fight Isis so far have
been failed disasters but he's going to
be great at some point and also Trump's
claims about voter fraud clearly have
rubbed off on at least some of his
supporters listen to this and we don't
know how to as far as the votes and
fraud and everything else
my assumption is that he probably would
have gotten elected by a higher number
then the results actually showed
extrapolating based on what I've seen
with my own eyes bus loads of people
coming in whether they're illegal
meaning they came into the country
illegally or they're illegal voters they
came over from Massachusetts into the
heavily armed cares I care because just
to be clear you saw with your own eyes
bus loads and bus loads of people coming
from somewhere other than your hampshire
to vote you saw that well I know Joshua
seen it yet I've seen it to Josh did you
see bus loads and bus loads of people
coming in from some other wouldn't
characterize it as possible that's what
I've seen cars coming in from out of
state listen I don't know anything about
bus loads of people coming in to vote
for Massachusetts I did see cars
circulating on our public roads though
and that I'm sure is something we should
look into right are they just hanging
out on the massachusetts new hampshire
border and looking for buses that's
what's going on this reminds us of not
only what little Trump has accomplished
because none of these people were able
to actually cite any accomplishments but
it reminds us of how out of touch Trump
supporters are and we often ask
ourselves who are the 35% 37% that
support of the jaw support the job Trump
is doing it's these people and it is as
stunning as you would imagine it to be
today's episode of the David Pakman show
is made possible in part by Warby Parker
eyeglasses Warby Parker recently did the
right thing and ditched advertising on
right-wing conspiracy website Breitbart
pulling their ads off and you can get
the free five-day home Tryon from Warby
Parker check out their glasses I use
them when I'm not wearing contact lenses
I started with the free at-home trial
they send you five pairs of glasses you
see which ones you like you send them
back and whichever one you pick they
will put your prescription into I like
this because I can actually show the
glasses to other people and not have to
just decide on the spot like in an
eyeglass store the eyeglass industry is
controlled by very few corporations that
keep the prices very very high even over
$300 for prescription glasses with Warby
Parker they start at just 95 bucks mine
cost that including lenses and for every
pair sold they give a pair to someone in
need so to try the five pairs and
support the David Pakman show go to
Warby Parker trial comm /t DPS